hello everyone and welcome back to the
things it's your host mu and today I'll
be taking you through everything we can
expect to see in the most highly
anticipated movie sequel of 2019 frozen
- be sure to keep on watching for
everything we know about the new
characters being introduced to us in
this magical sequel mm-hmm big summer
blowout now let's start off with some
pretty exciting news Kristen Bell who
voices honor has officially confirmed
the introduction of some new characters
in the movie sequel there are a ton of
theories floating around the internet of
who these characters might be a love
interest for Queen Elsa an antagonist
with some pretty special powers of their
own or maybe even so York and organ
brought to life this is heat or maybe
even a favorite for us here at the
things a female version of the hilarious
and fun-loving snowman Olaf check out
this video if you're interested in any
more frozen - theories and be sure to
let me know if any you can think of in
the comment section below
whoever these new characters turn out to
be what we know for sure is that they're
going to be played by Evan Rachel Wood
and Sterling Brown what has already
worked in the animated film industry
voicing character Marianne and strange
magic Marianne is a feisty and
strong-willed character making her
perfect practice for woods role in
frozen as for Sterling Brown some of you
might recognize him from NBC dramas
highly successful television series this
is us or maybe even as the cunning
antagonist from Marvel's Black Panthers
open those gates so I may unlock your
secrets and exploit your riches
this would make found a perfect
antagonist for the frozen sequel Alyson
Schroeder the writer behind hidden
figures is set to play a large role in
the screenwriting process now this tells
us that frozen is bound to be full of
Awesome messages of female empowerment
now it looks like the writers of the
movie are just as excited as we are
they've chosen to release it a whole
week earlier than the initial set date
fun fact
Olaf Stars and adventure aired a whole
year earlier on the same date November
22nd are you kidding me I am wonderful
now mark most calendars and get those
vocals ready because according to the
dr. Jennifer Lee we are being blessed
with four new and original songs and we
just can't let it go
Lee has mentioned that frozen 2 can also
be expected to be bigger and more epic
than the original with the girls
exploring far out of arendelle well we
can only guess where they might end up
we can definitely take it from the two
short films frozen fever and Olaf serves
an adventure in frozen fever on a
follows a string in the search for a
birthday present this guy's awake I'm
awake silly to play Olaf's frozen
adventure follows Olaf around the town
of arendelle searching for some
Christmas traditions now in both movies
the characters are on a journey to find
something indicating that this could
definitely still be the case in frozen -
some fans have even speculated that this
movie might be taking a page from lego
frozen northern Mike I definitely want
to know what you think about that one in
the comment section
this would make total sense as we do get
a glimpse of the Northern Lights and one
of the final scenes of Olaf's frozen
adventure and if I had to guess I would
say we have not seen the last of that
Hawke either check this out guys
John Lasseter the CCO of Disney and
Pixar Animation has hinted at this for
sure now he says that the short and the
sequel can be watched together for one
big movie marathon
spoiler alert guys he is also hinted
that this could be about another first
for the two sisters in frozen fever they
celebrate Ana's first birthday together
with the Castle adorned and sunflower
themed decorations this clearly marks
the start of the spring season and
Olaf's frozen adventure they celebrate
their first holiday season together
leading us into frozen - queena Doudna
is also set to play a pivotal role in
the sequel but this will probably be
through flashbacks you mean to tell me
you got engaged to someone you just met
that day now this would make total sense
it's according to movie pilot we are
going to be seeing a lot more of young
Elsa and the actress playing Air has
been confirmed to star in the movie this
will probably be giving us some more
insight into Elsa's magical childhood
songwriter anderson-lopez has mentioned
that they are definitely considering a
storyline for the hidden folk from
frozen's Broadway musical and
it's all we have for today guys it's
your host norm be sure to hit that
subscribe button give this video a big
thumbs up and hit me up on Instagram for
any other extra questions thank you for
watching and catch you next time my own
personal flurry
[Music]
[Music]